Benedicto 16 ha muerto este sábado en la
mañana del Vaticano la noticia fue
confirmada por la entidad católica que
lo despidió con campanadas
con conmoción el recorridamos la
suaperzona José inmóviles con emoción
recordamos su persona tan noble tan
bondadosa sentimos en nuestro corazón
tal gratitud gratitud a Dios por
habérselo regalado la iglesia y al mundo
gratitud a él por todo el bien que hizo
y especialmente por su testimonio de fe
y oración especialmente en estos últimos
años de su vida retirada
especialmente en cuestión
últimata los líderes del mundo
lamentaron el fallecimiento del
pontífice el canciller Alemán Olaf shots
despidió a su compatriota el primero en
llegar al alto mando de la santa sede
como un Papa alemán Benedicto 16 fue
para muchos no sólo en este país un
líder especial de la iglesia el mundo
pierde a una figura formadora de la
Iglesia Católica una personalidad
controvertida Y a un teólogo hábil mis
pensamientos están con el Papa Francisco
por su parte el presidente francés
Emmanuel macron se pronunció en
Solidaridad con los creyentes
mi pensamiento está con los católicos de
Francia y de todo el mundo afligidos por
la partida de su santidad Benedicto XVI
que trabajó con Alma e inteligencia por
un mundo más fraterno
de este lado del mundo el mandatario
entrante de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva recordó su encuentro con Benedicto
en la visita que el pontífice hizo en
2007 y deseó consuelo a los fieles del
líder católico
la capilla ardiente del Papa emérito se
hará desde el lunes hasta el miércoles
en la Basílica de San Pedro para que los
creyentes puedan dar su último adiós el
entierro será presido por su sucesor el
Papa Francisco el jueves 5 de enero